bonsoir le premier aimer dieu les hommes
et les oiseaux qui leur a dédié des
symphonies ou opéra le second aimait la
vie mais l'a représenté avec désespoir
dans des tableaux splendide olivier
messiaen et francis bacon nous ont
quittés aujourd'hui olivier messiaen
était le compositeur français le plus
célèbre de l'après guerre
il laisse une oeuvre immense et reconnue
dans le monde entier
discret et même parfois austère il a
accordé sa dernière interview télévisée
à claude glaymann c'était en décembre
dernier
en décembre dernier à radio france
olivier messiaen créé est une oeuvre en
hommage à mozart
la dernière création de son vivant sans
aucun doute olivier mission aura été le
plus grand musicien de la seconde moitié
du 20e siècle tant par son oeuvre propre
que par l'enseignement multiples qui
leur a prodigué
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus beaucoup de
mairies mais moi j'aime la mélodie je
continue en fait la mélodie ya surtout
des couleurs d'accord ça c'est pas
mauvais lorsqu'il le lisais de la
musique ans il écoutait où l'ism de la
musique
il voyait des sons et voyez les couleurs
les couleurs très complexe des accords
de couleurs et donc dans sa musique il a
voulu traduire ça aussi et il les a
décrites alors c'était des rouges
orangés pimenté d'argent etc
en face des choses extrêmement compliqué
et et pour lui c'était dans le front a
pu une richesse harmonique et son
langage c'était ça c'était à la fois une
richesse harmonique c'était aussi un
rapport particulier avec la nature c'est
pour ça que tu as tellement de chants
d'oiseaux dans toutes ses oeuvres
compositeur influencé également par
l'asie comme par la foi chrétienne
mais si on laisse un catalogue immense
et universel du quatuor pour la fin du
temps à la thur engaly la symphonie en
passant par le piano l'orgue ainsi que
par son opéra saint françois d'assise
qui coïncidence sera redonné au prochain
festival de salzbourg puis à la bastille
dans une nouvelle mise en scène
fr3 rendra hommage à olivier messiaen le
3 mai prochain
si mais si on cultivait la discrétion
francis bacon en revanche a souvent
choqué sa vie mouvementée ces tableaux
tournante et ont très vite fait de lui
un véritable monstre de la peinture
contemporaine
francis bacon avait 82 ans il s'est
éteint à madrid à la suite d'une crise
cardiaque
thierry stern fleurs francis bacon était
l'un des artistes contemporains les plus
côtés du monde certaines de ses toiles
atteignait les 40 millions de francs et
pourtant il se révéler complètement
détachée des choses matérielles bacon
vivait dans un petit deux pièces à
londres son minuscule atelier était à
capharnaüm tout à fait remarquable
il peignait cinq à six tableaux car en
seulement son travail généralement
décrit comme tourmenté sanglant laisse
pourtant une issue à l'espoir et c'est à
chacun d'entre nous à la découvrir
vous savez la plupart des gens habitent
la vie avec les voiles à vente
il ne regarde vraiment ce que c'est
notoirement homosexuels francis bacon
vivait intensément et les anecdotes le
concernant sont aussi nombreuses que
drôle
il aimait paris où césar connaissait un
formidable succès notamment lors de sa
dernière exposition à la galerie lelong
en 82
cometti ou parler de picasso de la
sculpture de picasso ça ça le concerne
est au fond la société là et la place
d'un artisan la société quand c'est le
sable ou dans ses tableaux le même je
pense que comme tous les grands artistes
qui il doutait fortement que ce parent
c'est quelqu'un qui détruisait aussi
comme des paysages giacometti est aussi
la raison pour laquelle le travail n'a
pas été abondants aux quantités
ces oeuvres datent de ces deux dernières
années elles sont consacrées à la
tauromachie et illustre un livre de
michel leiris un des grands amis de
francis bacon
à l'étranger c'est toujours
l'afghanistan et ses déchirements qui
font la une au fil des heures kaboul
aussi en effet entre guerre et paix paix
et joie ce matin pour l'arrivée du
président du conseil intérimaire combat
quelques heures plus tard dans le centre
même de la capitale jean-françois
gringoire c'est ainsi en afghanistan que
les moudjahidine manifestent leur joie
de grandes rafales de kalachnikov pour
saluer et pour célébrer
aux cris de allah est grand ses
partisans ont accueilli aujourd'hui le
président du conseil intérimaire
islamique
si le gâteau la mode j'ai dit 10 65 ans
de retour à kaboul après 20 ans d'exil
sa mission préparer des élections pour
dans six mois
vu l'ambiance de guerre qui règne
toujours à kaboul la tâche s'annonce
rude surtout que les adversaires du
président intérimaire estime que ce
dernier dirige une faction peu
représentatif du pays
si les combats avaient baissé
d'intensité ce matin après les
affrontements d'hier
la passation du pouvoir entre l'ancien
et le nouveau gouvernement afghan a
entraîné qu'une reprise des tirs tirs
entre les troupes fondamentalistes de
gulbuddin hekmatyar et la coalition
formée par les hommes du commandant
massoud et d'anciens soldats avec mme
attias et massoud grands rivaux pour la
bataille de kaboul campent sur des
positions si radicale que rien ne laisse
entrevoir ce soir un retour au calme
durable dans la capitale afghane
les juifs de syrie pourront désormais
émigrés librement la décision est
annoncée hier en fin de soirée
une décision qui prouve bien que les
scieries relâche du lest dans un moment
crucial aussi bien pour le proche-orient
qu'au niveau international
joël hasard c'est de la bouche même du
président assad que les représentants de
la communauté juive syrienne ont reçu
l'assurance qu'ils pourront désormais
voyager librement une image de dialogue
propre à rassurer israël à un moment
opportun avec la reprise des
négociations israélo arabe
un geste vis-à-vis de washington
destinée à faire oublier que la syrie
figurait sur la liste noire des pays
ayant soutenu le terrorisme
pour la petite communauté juive syrienne
environ 4000 âmes
cette décision présidentielle représente
une véritable libération les juifs
syriens vont pouvoir enfin sortir de
leur pays sans laisser derrière eux un
des leurs ni versé en caution 1000 $
geste politique du président assad ira
margaret tu devais leur le porte parole
du département d'état américain en
annonçant la levée des restrictions
discriminatoires à l'encontre des juifs
syrien commentaires délia kim rubinstein
le chef de la délégation israélienne aux
pourparlers de paix c'est un moment qui
ne peut apporter que de la joie à tous
les hommes libres et à tous les juifs où
qu'ils se trouvent
cette décision syrienne s'inscrit dans
la logique de la conférence de madrid
tels que les américains l'avaient des
filles la fin de la défiance la question
des juifs syrien avait donné lieu à de
violentes passe d'armes entre
délégations israéliennes et syriennes
le geste de damas constitue donc le
premier signe concret d'un apaisement
dans les négociations israélo arabe
l'europe maintenant et peu à peu la
paralysie gagne l'allemagne la grève du
secteur public s'est en effet
sérieusement intensifier aujourd'hui et
le secteur privé devrait suivre en
partie demain une grève qui ne pouvait
pas plus mal tomber pour helmut kohl le
chancelier doit en effet trouver des
fonds pour financer la réunification
chantal girouard encore plus nombreux à
être encore plus en retard au travail ce
matin
les allemands expérimente des désordres
auxquels ils ne sont pas habitués et qui
semble devoir s'aggraver aujourd'hui le
principal syndicat allemand a demandé à
cent mille fonctionnaires de se mettre
en grève contre 80 milles hier
outre-rhin ce sont les centrales
syndicales qui décident des secteurs où
la grèce doit s'appliquer et du nombre
de grévistes pour obtenir une efficacité
maximum résultat les perturbations
encore accrue aujourd'hui en particulier
dans les transports en commun et dans le
service du courrier
demain les salariés de la métallurgie de
la construction mécanique se joindront à
eux aussi au mouvement
les revendications salariales sont les
mêmes 9,5 pour cent d'augmentation 92
alors que le gouvernement refuse d'aller
au delà du chiffre de l'inflation 4 8%
le chancelier kohl en tant qu on paie
sur cette position de fermeté malgré une
situation politique particulièrement
défavorable les investissements tardent
à arriver dans l'ex-allemagne de l'est
qui compte désormais 3 millions de
chômeurs la coalition de centre-droit
multiplie les défaites dans les scrutins
régionaux les sondages confirment la
tendance
de toute évidence les allemands de
l'ouest sont de moins en moins prêts à
régler l'énorme facture de la
réunification
dernier coup dur pour helmut kohl le
départ dense dietrich genscher son
ministre des affaires étrangères la
presse allemande se demandait ce matin
si ce fin politique n'avait pas
volontairement quitter un navire en
train de couler l'europe l'europe
économique est ainsi au centre de
l'actualité française c'est en effet
aujourd'hui que s'ouvrait au parlement
la procédure concernant la réforme de la
constitution avant les accords de
maastricht ses premières prises de
position à la commission des lois
pourraient s'apparenter un tour de
chauffe
mais dans l'ensemble vous allez le voir
c'est le consensus jean baptiste près
dalli patrick müller ou même par de
l'hémicycle les débats à l'assemblée
peuvent être animé commission des lois
ce matin la publicité des travaux y est
peut-être pour quelque chose
le sujet aussi officiellement la
révision constitutionnelle
en fait le garde des sceaux michel
vauzelle elisabeth guigou le ministre
des affaires européennes ont affronté
leurs premières discussions de fond sur
matriche arguments connus pour une parti
d'opposition le traité menacerait la
souveraineté nationale faux réplique le
gouvernement il implique des transferts
de compétences non de souveraineté
deuxième argument le calendrier
transféré pour le rpr une semaine entre
la discussion en commission et la séance
plénière il faut que nous sachions
comment modifions nos institutions pour
aller vers l'union européenne et pour
cette question il faut beaucoup de temps
et beaucoup de réflexion et je crois que
le gouvernement s'il veut nous faire
travailler à marche forcée démontrera
quand fait masse tricher pour lui un
coup politique
un coup de politique intérieure et non
pas réellement une étape dans la
construction de l'europe les
parlementaires souhaitent avoir
approfondir leurs connaissances du
traité c'est très bien le gouvernement a
manifesté sa disponibilité à être sa
disponibilité dans le cadre de les
limites on ne pas renégocier le traité
je pense que cela augure bien de la
poursuite de la poursuite des travaux
au total trois heures de discussions
techniques et politiques une opposition
plutôt conciliante avec l'udf prête à
ratifier après amendement surtout ce
matin une répétition générale avant le
grand débat de mardi
et au moment où s'engage cette procédure
au parlement il devient urgent pour le
rpr de repréciser ses positions face à
la récente de la constitution c'est la
raison pour laquelle un conseil national
se tenait ce soir à paris et jacques
chirac a un peu nuancer ses premières
déclarations
jacques chirac j'ai dit que maastricht
n'étaient rien d'autre en réalité qu'un
petit pas dans une direction souhaitable
et c'est ça la vérité c'est ça
non je comprends bien sûr que certains
expriment de légitimes inquiétudes j'en
ai parlé longuement très longuement avec
beaucoup d'entre vous et il est
important pour nous d'entendre de
comprendre ces inquiétudes et d'en
discuter
l europe toujours l'europe au centre du
conflit des dockers la réforme proposée
par le gouvernement veut relancer les
ports français avant l ouverture des
frontières
jusqu alors la cgt ne voulait pas
entendre parler d'un changement de
statut elle a proposé aujourd'hui des
amendements au projet de loi
cette fois c'est le gouvernement qui
réfléchit réponse demain claire
sébastien et pierre michel
c'est avec des propositions dite
d'ouverture que la délégation cgt des
ports et docks qui est arrivé ce matin
au ministère de la mer l'enjeu de cette
rencontre avec charles josselin
successeur d' yves le drian héritier de
la réforme du statut des dockers se
chiffre à un milliard de francs c'est en
effet à peu près le coût du conflit qui
paralyse les ports français depuis six
mois alors que sur le terrain la grève a
été suspendue depuis lundi la cgt semble
aujourd'hui moins intransigeante sur le
retrait pur et simple du projet de loi
des propositions d'amendements ont été
déposés un effet sur le bureau du
ministre concernant deux points
importants
la mensualisation des dockers et
l'adaptation de leurs effectifs au
besoin de chaque port sur la question de
la mensualisation qui est considéré
comme un des piliers de la réforme
là dessus nous avons beaucoup réfléchi
et nous avons fait une proposition qui
permet de répondre à cette question mais
en l'adaptant aux spécificités de
l'activité portuaire
si charles josselin reconnu qu'il y
avait matière à réflexion dans les
nouvelles propositions de la cgt
il ne les a pas pour autant considérées
comme positives la réponse définitive du
gouvernement est attendu dans les
prochains jours
l'échec des pourparlers entraînerait
selon la cgt une reprise du conflit et
l'agenda social du gouvernement est
décidément bien chargé pierre bérégovoy
recevait aujourd'hui gens cassent pas au
menu des discussions le chômage le
secrétaire général de la cfdt demandé la
tenue d'états généraux de l'emploi
il a en partie gain de cause jean kaspar
il y a une volonté de donc de mettre en
route ces états régionaux sur l'emploi
je crois que cela est un élément tout à
fait positif
il y a également la volonté pour le
premier ministre il ça je crois que
c'est un élément important de refaire le
point sur le projet de loi sur le
travail de nuit et sur les compensations
en particulier dans le domaine de la
réduction du temps de travail et j'ai
senti de la part du produit une liste
une volonté de s'attaquer sur le fond de
l'évolution des systèmes de retraite et
en essayant de faire en sorte que nous
puissions progresser sur ce terrain là
aussi et puis on vient de l'apprendre
dans la sphère de la société générale le
président de la société mars aux
investissements georges pébereau a été
inculpé cet après midi inculpée de non
déclaration de franchissement de seuil
georges pébereau est l instigateur du
raid économiques lancées contre la
société générale
il n'y aura pas de nouveau scandale du
sang l'immunoglobuline accusé par
certains de pouvoir transmettre le virus
de l'hépatite c s'avère en fait sans
danger le comité de sécurité
transfusionnelle réunis en urgence à
lever tous les doutes
le médicament sera donc à nouveau
commercialiser sans restriction
jean-pierre quinson laurent pelletier
les produits en question ce sont les
immunoglobulines des produits préparés à
partir de sang ou de placenta humain est
donnée à certains malades pour renforcer
leurs défenses immunitaires
la polémique a été lancée par plusieurs
journaux dont l'express de cette semaine
sur l'aide de madère s'est
immunoglobulines sa part préparé avec du
plasma n'ayant pas subi le test de
dépistage du virus de l'hépatite c
toujours selon ce journal elle pourrait
donc transmettre cette forme d'hépatite
une hypothèse fausse sur les fabricants
puisque d'après eux les méthodes de
préparation des produits font appel à
des techniques rendant le virus inactif
le comité sécurité de la transfusion
réuni hier par le mît de la santé leur
donne entièrement raison et même estime
qu'il ya danger à diffuser de telles
informations
le risque poésie ne lui bling il est
muet sur le plan de transmission de
l'hépatite chronique c actuellement dans
l'état actuel des connaissances et il
est même dangereux d'interrompre la
transmission d une bobine car parler
pour les femmes enceintes par exemple
qui auraient besoin d'une noble indh et
dans des circonstances médicales très
particulière l'interruption ses yeux
bleus blinn pourrait avoir des
conséquences catastrophiques
fort de cet avis pasteur mérieux qui
avait suspendu hier la diffusion de
certains immunoglobulines a décidé
aujourd'hui temps reprend la
distribution
je crois que le grand public doit être
rassuré lui puisque dès qu'il y ait un
doute le ministère prend une position de
prudence réunit des experts nous nous
suspendons une exploitation dès que la
vie est de nouveau favorable on reprend
l'exploitation
donc c'est une garantie de sécurité en
définitive vraisemblablement une fausse
alerte ce qui est certain c'est que le
précédent du si dans 85 a permis de
donner à ce genre d'informations
un caractère sensationnel sans doute
démesuré en donnant quelques unes de vos
pièces jaunes vous pourriez mettre un
rayon de soleil dans les hôpitaux pour
la deuxième année consécutive la poste
et les hôpitaux de paris lance en effet
une collecte pour améliorer l'accueil et
l'environnement des enfants malades
cette initiative est publique mais
parfois des entreprises privées font de
même ainsi à villejuif mcdonald's a
financé une maison qui héberge les
parents d'enfants cancéreux un soutien
énorme pour des familles qui en ont tant
besoin catherine matausch et
jean-jacques le deuil y ont rencontré
flavie et ses parents elie comment cette
maison par rapport à tous les ans
maintenant pourquoi pas une très belle
promotion
on peut regarder la télé et aux seniors
jouer avec d'autres enfants plutôt que
de rester dans une chambre d'hôpital ou
chez soi pour flavie cinq ans qui a
aujourd'hui retrouvé des forces
cela est essentiel la maison des parents
comme on l'appelle a beau vivre à
l'ombre du premier centre européen de
lutte contre le cancer
elle n'est pas l'hôpital cet hôpital qui
surgit comme un mur du silence
quand on a passé toute une journée à
l'hôpital et puis qu'on a vu que ça va
pas bien avec l'enfant dès qu on entre
ici on sent et puis a toujours quelqu'un
ici donc la maison n'est jamais vide
déjà de bons c'est ça quand on sort de
l'hôpital on sait que la maison n'est
pas vide
donc il y aura quelqu'un qui sera là
pour nous écouter si l'enfant n'est pas
été bien pour pouvoir déverser un petit
peu l' angoisse qu'on a eu pendant la
journée à l'hôpital
à deux pas de l'hôpital une vingtaine de
parents vivent ici presque comme chez
eux pour 50 francs par jour il y forme
quasiment une communauté ou l'entr'aide
permet d'être auprès de son enfant
malade à tout moment cette maison
permettent aussi de quitter la maladie
une maladie qui ne tue plus dans les
trois quarts des cas à l'institut
gustave roussy
cette maison est une maison qui prépare
à la guérison à la vie finalement et la
qualité du souvenir que les parents et
les enfants garderont de la maladie fera
que peut-être nous espérons guérison
sera de meilleure qualité dans certains
cas 21h pendant que la plupart des
parents reviennent à la maison laissant
derrière eux à l'hôpital leurs enfants
flavie elle mange des yeux la télévision
véritable compagnon dans la maladie
merlin l'enchanteur est là pour rappeler
tout simplement que la vie continue
non bizarroïde prénom ridicule l'état
civil n'a jamais été tendre avec ceux
dont le patronyme n'est pas toujours
facile à porter depuis 10 ans on parle
d'une réforme qui faciliterait le
changement de nom elle a à nouveau été
examinée à l'assemblée cet après midi ce
projet de loi serait le bienvenu on
enregistre en effet une vague
extraordinaire de demandes et les gens
ne changent pas forcément de nom pour
les raisons qu'on imagine reportage aux
archives le lieu stratégique
dan rongère et josiane szymanski si je
vous dit pardonnez-moi connard alors
connard et le est un cas intéressant
parce que c'est un nom d'origine
germanique la racine comme des i
quelqu'un de hardy de braves
hélas depuis le moyen âge le sens c'est
bien changé et dans les cours d'école
les petits crétins couillon et autres
noms d'oiseaux en dur les blague cruelle
de leurs camarades
mais une fois adulte on peut s'offrir un
nom tout neuf
grâce à ce service des archives de
lettres en moi un anagramme et le tour
est joué
assassin devient asselin brouillard trop
viard et courtecuisse courtecuisse
on peut éventuellement abrégé non en
courtis mais les noms ridicules ne
représentent qu'un quart des demandes de
changement
le reste des noms à consonance étrangère
au fil des années monsieur l'archiviste
s'est transformé en sociologue désir
d'intégration ou refoulement du passé le
changement de nom cache d'autres enjeux
c'est un acte grave parce que c'est une
rupture avec le passé c'est une rupture
avec l'histoire
de la famille c'est une rupture avec les
origines et très souvent ces personnes
qui demandent à changer de nom prennent
1 n'ont pu être par le sont relativement
aux offres mais les candidats aux
changements ne sont pas au bout de leurs
peines garde des sceaux journal officiel
conseil d'état leur parcours juridique
dure souvent plus de dix ans dernière
journée de ski pour les amoureux de la
montagne et premier bilan dans les
stations vous allez le voir les
bénéficiaires des jeux olympiques ne
sont pas toujours ceux que l'on croit
effrayé par l'organisation des jo de
nombreux skieurs ont boudé la savoie
cette année
résultat l'isère à profiter par ricochet
des jeux à l'alpe d'huez les comptes
n'ont jamais été aussi bons alors
qu'ailleurs c'est un peu la morosité
caroline since christian de carnets sur
place l'alpe d'huez est un géant du
tourisme alpin cinquième budget de
l'isère est l'un des domaines skiables
les plus étendu d'europe à plus de 3000
mètres d'altitude cette station est
pourtant loin de l' asphyxie financière
à titre d'exemple avec nos voisins et
amis des deux alpes la station de l'alpe
d'huez réalisent la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires général du tourisme dans le
département de l'isère
le chiffre d'affaires du tourisme dans
le département d'isère est un peu
supérieure à quatre milliard 4 milliards
et demi de francs
l'alpe d'huez et les 2 ap l'oiseau en
général font un peu plus de 50 %
c'est-à-dire un chiffre d'affaires
supérieur à 2 milliards ou 2 milliards
200 millions
pas de morosité de fin de saison ici les
chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes 152
millions gagnés cet hiver par les
remontées mécaniques la station investit
pourtant à coups de millions pour
conserver et attirer une nouvelle
clientèle phénomène récent l'afflux
d'étrangers
pendant les jeux olympiques ils ont
préféré l'isère à la savoie première
conséquence le travail des moniteurs de
ski en pleine évolution
il est nécessaire de s'adapter cet élan
tél c'est à dire de former un certain
nombre de moniteurs de regarder aussi un
petit peu dans quel sens va là
la clientèle est d'essayer de former les
moniteurs dans la langue qui correspond
à la clientèle de la station pour ne pas
se faire doubler par les moniteurs
étrangers
le sf a même préféré engager entre
autres des japonais et d argent que la
nécessaire appel d'air mais peut-être au
risque d'y perdre son âme sa station
conserve toujours son caractère
d'ailleurs c'est passé apprécié
justement par les étrangers puisque nous
avons une clientèle étrangère mais mais
ce n'est pas une clientèle qui domine la
station conserve un caractère tout à
fait français et c'est très apprécié par
la plupart de nos clients
mais les vacances de pâques trop tardive
n'ont pas fait le plein l'alpe d'huez
côté pile c'est aussi une montagne
entretenir versant d'un travail méconnu
si on a terminé la saison alors
maintenant bon puis tout le matériel qui
est sur les pylônes et sur les pilotes
et puis on démonte les perches des
téléskis pour après el papa réparation
et sur leurs pareils systématiquement
toutes les zones et après avoir pansé
les plaies de lit vers l'alpe d'huez
s'élancera vers l'été car ici l'or blanc
est un marché l'éternel et pour terminer
les rapports du tiercé quarté + quinté
plus pour le tiercé il fallait jouer le
8 le 9 et le 11 ce vous laisse découvrir
les rapports pour le quarté + 8 9 11 et
3 et pour le quinté + 8 9 11 3 et 6 voix
la fin du 19 20 le prochain rendez vous
avec la rédaction c'est à 22h34 soir 3
présenté par marc hautement en quelques
secondes la météo complète de florence
klein à demain 19h bonsoir
mon genou